-Rupert, welcome.
-Thank you for having me.
-Well, I'm so happy you're here,
because I want to get into
a bunch of things.
But I know that when you joined
Instagram, it was a big deal.
You broke the
Guinness World Record
for the fastest person
to reach 1 million followers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-True. That's true.
I know.
-Now, here is actually
the first post right here.
It says, "Hey, Instagram.
Only 10 years late,
but here I am.
Grint on the Gram.
Here to introduce you all
to Wednesday G. Grint.
Stay safe. Rupert."
I mean, how beautiful is that?
Come on, you got --
-Yeah. No, it was -- I mean,
I resisted joining
Instagram for a long time.
-Why?
-Just because I just --
Ultimately, I think it just
doesn't go with my personality.
-No.
-I'm quite a shy person,
and the thought of kind of
sharing my life just didn't seem
like it would really --
-Yeah.
Are you good on Instagram?
-No, I'm terrible.
Just -- It's really hard.
Like, I never know what to post.
-Well, I looked at
your Instagram
to see what other things
we could show.
You've only posted like
three other times since that.
So you just kind of
just stopped and you go,
"That's not my deal."
-Yeah, it's mainly
"Servant" trailers
and the back of my
daughter's head.
-Yeah.
How is your baby daughter?
-She's great.
-Oh, congratulations.
How old?
-Thank you.
Yeah, she's nearly 2.
She's like 21 months.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It's great.
-Oh, and great name, by the way.
Wednesday?
-It's a good name, isn't it?
-Yes, I love Wednesday.
-It's a strong name. Yeah.
-Why Wednesday?
-Well, I mean,
I'm always hesitant to say
it was "The Addams Family,"
but, it was, yeah,
kind of "The Addams Family."
I just always loved the name.
-It's a cool --
It's a great name.
-It's a good name.
It's kind of -- It's punchy.
-Wednesday G. Grint.
-It's kind of memorable.
-And the "G" -- what is that?
-Yeah, so, actually,
Samuel L. Jackson
kind of inspired that.
-For real?
-Yeah, we loved the idea of,
like, an initial,
like Samuel L. Jackson,
Michael J. Fox,
that kind of
speaking the initial.
So she's Wednesday G. Grint.
-Yes, I love that.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
And fatherhood so far,
you loving it?
-Loving it, yeah.
It's brilliant.
Now she's kind of
talking and doing things,
'cause for so long,
babies just don't do anything.
-No, they actually
don't do anything, yeah.
But now she's actually speaking?
-She's speaking. She's talking.
She's got opinions.
-She has opinions.
Did she say
"dada" or "mama" first?
-She says "dada."
She says "mama."
It was kind at the same time.
And, also, the F-word
came pretty quick.
-Your baby says the F-word?
-She does.
But she spends a lot of time
outside my dressing room
when I'm kind of doing
my lines for this,
and my character says
the F-word a lot.
And now she just says
it whenever she's excited.
We took her to -- Actually,
we were in a toy store today,
and she was just walking around
just jumping at every --
-And do people laugh
or what do people do?
-Yeah, it's kind of
a mixed reaction.
We find it hilarious,
so it's kind of encouraging it,
but --
-How big is -- She's tiny.
-She's small.
Yeah, she's really small.
-And says that.
-Yeah. Like I said --
-Wednesday, watch it, watch it.
You'll watch this clip one day
and -- Yeah.
It's hard to believe,
but you celebrated --
Is it 20th anniversary
of the first "Harry Potter"?
-20 years, yeah.
-20 years ago. And --
-Thank you. I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were a baby.
-Yeah.
And you had the big reunion with
a special with your castmates.
Did you get along like,
"Oh, yeah,
it's just like,
yeah, nothing, like --"
It's just like riding a bike?
You're like, "Yeah,
we know how to do this."
-Yeah, it was kind of -- We just
kind of clicked straight
back into --
I mean, it's been a long time.
It's been 10 years since we
wrapped the last movie,
and, yeah, time has past.
I do feel like an old man now.
-But you grew up --
I mean, you grew up on
the sets with those --
-Yeah, well, that's the thing.
It's kind of more than
just eight films.
It's like it was our childhood.
-Yeah. Now you have a baby,
a beautiful baby,
and you're going to show her
these movies one day
and go, "That's dad."
-Yeah, yeah, I know.
I mean, I've already started
showing her
the trailers, and she has a wand
and a PEZ dispenser
with my head on it.
-She has a PEZ dispenser
with your head on it?
-We don't feed her PEZ,
but she has --
-So every time you pull
daddy's head back,
candy comes out of his neck?
-Out of my throat, yeah.
-That's frightening, yeah.
-It's kind of disturbing.
-You can't do that --
-She's going with it.
-Well, let's talk about
"Servant," because this is --
It's the third season,
renewed for a fourth season.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you, yeah.
M. Night Shyamalan is
brilliant -- beyond brilliant.
I love that guy.
-Yeah.
-You do a great American accent,
by the way.
-Yeah, so, yeah, sort of --
-Oh, yeah, it's alright.
Yeah, I can't do
British accents.
[ British accent ]
I can't do that, you know?
-Oh, that's quite good.
-Yeah, it's alright?
-Yeah, that's alright.
I'll buy that.
-So it's alright.
Yeah, of course.
[ Normal voice ]
But that's all I can say.
Is there a word
that's really hard to say
in an American accent?
-Yeah, I mean, there's a few
that kind of trip you up.
One that stands out for me
was "floorboards."
-Floorboards.
-[ American accent ] Floorboard.
[ Normal voice ] Yeah,
it's like a -- I just --
-You almost had
a Scottish or Irish.
-Yeah, yeah.
-[ Scottish accent ] Floorboard.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I just add like seven R's.
-R's, yeah.
-But I think -- I don't know.
It's lucky that it's not a word
that comes up very often.
-Yeah, that's true.
It's not in many scripts.
It's like, "can I change
the word 'floorboard' here?
Is this a problem for anybody?"
Yeah. Can you tell everyone, on
"Servant," who you play?
-Sure, yeah.
So -- Oh, man, I'm so bad
at explaining the show.
-You can kind of --
I'll help you out.
-Okay, yeah.
So, yeah, I play Julian.
I'm Dorothy's brother.
Dorothy's just lost a baby.
We meet her six months later,
and she's going through this
radical therapy
where she uses a doll
to kind of replace
the loss of her son.
-But in the show,
you also get a nanny.
-We get a nanny
to look after the doll.
-The doll.
-Yeah.
It kind of spirals out of
control, and --
-It's M. Night, so it's, like --
You want those types of things
to happen,
so it's all trippy and --
-Yeah, yeah, it's very trippy.
It kind of treads the line --
You never really know
if there's kind of a
supernatural element going on.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's a really fun show.
-It's well done.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Rupert Grint
in the new season of "Servant."
Take a look.
-Uh, it's crooked.
Look, you asked for my help.
-[ Sighs ]
I was worried about you.
I hadn't seen you lurking
around, raiding our fridge.
-Five years of experience
of avoiding Dorothy's wrath.
-You think she'll like it?
-Yeah, she always did.
It's supposed to be about
oppressed vaginas.
I just see a black hole.
Or are you asking me if it'll
make Dorothy like you again?
-I'm doing every [bleep]
I can think of.
I'm going to fix [bleep]
in the entry.
Will you grab the tool bag?
-Yeah, you go ahead.
I'll, uh, catch up.
-Yeah, Rupert Grint, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
New episodes of "Servant"
are available now on Apple TV+.